j'ouvre notre second débat consacré à un
réseau social qui cartonne chez les plus
jeunes Tik Tok ses vidéos ultra courtes
et addictives séduisent plus d'un
milliard 700 millions de personnes sur
la planète mais sont propriétaire
chinois fait naître des soupçons
d'espionnage d'outils d'influence
résultats plusieurs pays sont en train
d'interdire l'appli à leur
fonctionnaires Cécile
l'appli préféré des ados Tic-Toc était
un outil d'espionnage chinois cette
question inquiète en tout cas la
communauté internationale après
l'interdiction faite au personnel de la
Commission européenne utilisait
l'application sur leurs appareils
professionnels le Sénat français a créé
une commission d'enquête et les
États-Unis menacent carrément de bannir
le réseau social du pays Tik Tok pose un
problème et constitue une problématique
nous nous inquiétons pour les données
des Américains la collecte des données
des Américains et le risque potentiel en
matière de sécurité nationale
Tik Tok peut collecter les données de
ces usagers via la caméra le micro la
localisation ou encore les contacts du
téléphone mais personne ne sait ce qui
en effet ces informations elles sont
potentiellement exportées du téléphone
envoyé quelque part sur des serveurs on
ne maîtrise pas nécessairement et sur
lequel on a clairement aucune
information sur les traitements qui sont
appliqués à ces informations collectées
les applications américaines Twitter
Facebook ou encore Instagram peuvent
aussi y avoir recours mais pour se
spécialiste des réseaux sociaux
l'inquiétude vient surtout du système
politique chinois pour une entreprise
proche du pouvoir chinois en
l'occurrence et bien on imagine qu'il y
a pas les mêmes contraintes que dans une
grande démocratie en gros je crois que
ce qui nous fait peur là et bien c'est
le côté une dictature à créer un outil
de surveillance qu'il a glissé dans la
poche de nos dirigeants jusqu'à nos
enfants et ça ça fait peur à tout le
monde peur aussi de l'addiction que
provoque la plateforme chez les jeunes
ils y passent en moyenne une heure 47
par jour
beaucoup de thèmes passionnants à
évoquer avec mes invités Claude malure
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes sénateurs de
l'Allier président du groupe Les
Indépendants républicains et territoire
et rapporteurs de cette commission
d'enquête sur justement l'utilisation du
réseau social Tik Tok son exploitation
des données ça stratégie d'influence les
travaux de cette commission vient
viennent de démarrer à ce moment-là
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes spécialisé
dans le politique et géopolitique de la
tech et enseignantation SPO et Columbia
j'essaie Anthony zambard bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi journaliste au
service international de challenge et
vous publiez trahison à la DGSE c'est
votre dernier livre et puis juste avant
franchine les liaisons dangereuses aux
éditions
Stock et évidemment Emily s'appelle ski
est restée à mes côtés éditorisent pour
sens publique Claude malouresse commence
avec vous quel est le l'objectif de
cette commission d'enquête pourquoi
ciblez-vous d'une certaine façon TikTok
d'abord parce que il faut il est
difficile de faire une commission
d'enquête sur l'ensemble des plateformes
parce qu'on en a pour de travail
deuxièmement parce que Tik Tok est quand
même très très spécifique d'abord elle
vient d'arriver c'est la plus récente et
par conséquent sur les autres on a
depuis longtemps des
enquêtes de journalistes des commissions
d'enquête etc etc Tic-Toc c'est pas
encore le cas et notamment c'est pas
encore le cas en France et puis il y a
quand même un certain nombre de
spécificités d'abord Tik Tok s'adresse
très majoritairement à des adolescents
et à des enfants donc un public
particulièrement fragile deuxièmement
beaucoup de régulateurs ont font des
enquêtes actuellement et comme la CNIL
ont condamné Tik Tok a des Allemands
pour différentes raisons d'abord la non
le non-respect des
volontés des utilisateurs deuxièmement
le transfert de données et notamment le
transfert de données en Chine qu'elle a
d'ailleurs que l'application a
d'ailleurs reconnu et puis comme on le
disait à l'instant sur votre reportage
le fait que la maison mère de Tik Tok by
dance soit une société chinoise avec
tous les toutes les contraintes qui sait
qui
heureux de la loi chinoise 2017 qui
oblige toute société
avec des services de renseignement et
qui place dans les grandes sociétés
c'est le cas de by dance la maison mère
une cellule du Parti communiste dans la
direction donc on n'est pas chez Google
ou Facebook qui veulent vous vendre tel
ou tel truc en reprenant vos données on
est avec le Parti communiste chinois qui
a accès aux données quand vous
téléchargez l'appli que que vous avez
dans votre téléphone posez les
différents enjeux et on va les détailler
évidemment pendant ce débat à ce
moment-là qu'est-ce qu'on sait de
l'exploitation des données justement par
TikTok et ses liens avec les taches
chinois avec le Malhuret un peu répandu
mais est-ce que c'est c'est toutes les
sociétés chinoises finalement qui ont un
bureau entre guillemets du Parti
communiste
présent dans les locaux quoi dans
certaines façons c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ça il y a deux lois en
Chine qui sont sorties loin sur la
cybersécurité en 2017 et plus récemment
2021 et qui peuvent qui
demander ou exiger soit une ouverture
algorithmique sur certaines plateformes
ou applications dites critiques soit
exiger une certaine vision ligne
éditoriale ou plutôt l'encourager plutôt
que d'ailleurs l'exiger ça c'est plutôt
les dernières salles réglementaires de
2021 et 2022 et en particulier mars 2022
donc la question du lien direct et de
l'accès direct de Pékin pour des usages
d'influence et politiques aujourd'hui la
preuve n'en est pas faite en revanche
qu'il y ait eu des excès aux données qui
sont collectées et sont des collectes
absolument massives de données par
TikTok et d'ailleurs des utilisateurs
mais aussi des gens qui ne sont pas sur
l'App sur l'application comment font-ils
en fait par tout un tas de systèmes de
trackers et de cookies etc qu'on a en
fait et qu'on accepte rapidement pour
pour avoir tel ou tel service en réalité
il y a une capacité et je crois 28 000
entreprises sont sont associés à ça et
permettent de remonter un certain nombre
de données pour du ciblage publicitaire
mais on le sait très bien une fois qu'on
a une capacité pour faire du ciblage
publicitaire très vite et très
rapidement l'usage peut être dévié vers
des ciblages cette fois-ci politique et
d'ailleurs il y a la question des
ingérences et de l'influence entre état
mais il y a aussi la manipulation comme
bridgeta par les partis politiques
eux-mêmes le marketing politique le
microsiblage politique etc donc ça pose
des questions fondamentales sur la
question donc je reviens quand même sur
votre question initiale parce que je
veux arriver à un point qui est celui-là
est-ce que il y a un risque oui est-ce
qu'il y a une preuve aujourd'hui directe
entre le PCC et l'accès le Parti
communiste parce que c'est ça le sujet
et un accès direct pour des une
stratégie d'influence ou de
cyberespionnage de façon directe et
frontale on en a pas la preuve mais ça
pose la question fondamentale pour nous
démocratie de est-ce qu'on anticipe et
c'est une vraie question qui qui qu'on
peut trancher d'un point de vue
politique est-ce qu'on anticipe le
risque réel surtout dans un dans une
logique aujourd'hui multipolaire de
fragmentation et de découplage ou est-ce
que on continue à poursuivre la question
de la preuve et donc du chemin du droit
et ça pose et on se poserait clairement
la question est-ce qu'il faut aller
jusqu'à interdire un réseau social comme
comme TiK ToK on y reviendra un peu plus
tard un peu politique on est bien
d'accord Antoine ils en bas je reviens
sur l'action de la preuve parce que ça
c'est quand même intéressant est-ce que
ce sera possible de prouver le lien
entre alors là on reste sur Tik Tok qui
serait un cheval de Troie de l'État
chinois est-ce que est-ce qu'on peut
arriver à prouver ça on a l'exemple de
Huawei Huawei aujourd'hui on a à peu
près on va dire 5-6 ans de recul par
rapport à la guerre déclenchée par les
États-Unis en 2017-2018
je dirais qu'aujourd'hui sur Huawei on a
un faisceau de d'indices qui enfin
d'éléments qui nous amène à penser que
c'est une société qui est qui pose des
problèmes
le skate c'est de la téléphonie donc il
y a peut-être plus de capacité Huawei je
sais pas
justement à récupérer des données
multiples et variées
c'est vraiment alors fondé en 87 par un
ancien colonel de l'armée populaire de
libération c'est quasiment 200000
employés contre aujourd'hui à peu près
un peu plus de 100000 pour byteens c'est
100 milliards d'euros de dollars de
chiffre d'affaires c'est la maison mère
de Tik Tok voilà donc 100 milliards
Huawei aujourd'hui on est à peu près à
9,4 et Huawei ont été une boîte qui
faisait à l'époque des câbles
sous-marins des smartphones de
l'infrastructure réseau voilà donc il
était quand même un mastodonte capable
de tout faire ce qui a été prouvé sur
Huawei c'est que dans beaucoup de
beaucoup de salariés de Huawei
travailler en même temps pour l'armée ou
pour les services de renseignement
chinois
donc ça ça a été quand même assez
démontré qu'il y avait des projets qui
étaient développés par Huawei qui était
après utilisé par l'armée donc il y
avait un lien qui a été évident après
sur la preuve on va dire les fameuses
bagues d'or et le fait que dans du
matériel Huawei finalement il y a des
dérivés qui arrivent jusqu'à à Pékin au
Shanghai on a eu un exemple notamment en
2018 où le siège de l'Union africaine à
Addis-Abeba ça a été démontré en 2018
avait des éléments des fuites en fait de
donner nocturnes à 4h du matin je crois
qu'il arrive à Shanghai et c'était à
travers un matériel de Huawei donc là ça
a été mais il y a encore une fois c'est
vraiment la question qui est qui est
très compliqué on est pas sûr qu'on est
des réponses en tout cas dans les médias
là-dessus à ce moment-là cette suspicion
suspicion pardon qui entoure Tik Tok
elle vient des États-Unis c'est pas un
hasard je pense qu'il faut il faut très
vite dans le débat parler de ça quoi et
Thomas en fait vous faites une
transition parce que ce qui vient d'être
dit qui est en fait très juste et c'est
merci pour l'exemple l'exemple de Huawei
parce qu'en fait c'est pas un exemple il
est en train de se passer quelque chose
aux États-Unis qui est d'ailleurs qui
est qui relève davantage de la politique
intérieure américaine qui est d'ailleurs
arrive à faire une coalition bip
artisanale entre républicains démocrates
qui est absolument une très très rare
particulièrement rare et donc en fait
c'est une espèce de je fabrique de
l'ennemi est-ce à dire que il y a un
problème avec ça non aujourd'hui on est
dans un jeu de compétition stratégique
et de rivaliser de puissance et toute la
question des États-Unis et de savoir
comment est-ce qu'ils vont maintenir
leur leadership chahuter par la Chine et
notamment et notamment la question
technologique cristallise complètement
totalement fondamentalement cette
rivalité Huawei mais avant Huawei ça a
commencé bien avant ça ça commençait par
le blocage de projet de câble sous-marin
par Obama Huawei était dans les
consortium donc en fait à chaque fois on
a un objet qui va venir projeter cette
rivalité systémique en réalité Claude
malure est-ce que c'est un enjeu
américain qu'on est en train d'importer
en France d'une certaine ou en Europe je
pense pas c'est un enjeu mondial et
c'est notamment un enjeu européen et
d'ailleurs si la Commission européenne
c'est le Parlement européen si le
gouvernement danois et un certain nombre
de gouvernements ont déjà interdit à
leur fonctionnaires de télécharger
l'application et le gouvernement
français d'ailleurs ce qu'on ne sait pas
elle a déjà interdit dans les ministères
régaliens il n'a pas fait de publicité
mais à la défense ou à l'intérieur vous
avez pas le droit de télécharger la
piste ça veut bien dire qu'il y a un
problème c'est pas spécialement
américain
à ce moment-là disait tout à l'heure à
juste titre il y a un risque il y a pas
de preuve
moi je suis pas spécialiste
d'informatique particulièrement mais je
connais peut-être un peu mieux le Parti
communiste chinois quand il y a un
risque est capable avec le Parti
communiste chinois je
préconiserai de me méfier beaucoup de la
prévention
de faire de la prévention mais
la deuxième raison Amérique Chine
peut-être mais c'est
depuis des décennies maintenant et
notamment depuis le début des années
2000 la Chine a fait ce bon en avant pas
sur le pas le même que je suis mais
c'est cette progression considérable
tout le monde le sait par un espionnage
massif permanent et notamment la
nationale bien entendu aux États-Unis
encore plus qu'en Europe par conséquent
si un risque est pas une preuve je pense
qu'il faut qu'il faut se préoccuper du
risque deuxièmement est-ce que c'est
est-ce que les Américains sont trop en
pointe là-dessus etc moi je constate une
chose c'est qu'en général les Américains
prévoient plus rapidement que nous ce
qui va se passer rappelez-vous de
l'Ukraine pendant des pendant des
semaines on a dit tous les Européens du
non non non ils vont pas envahir
l'Ukraine et pendant des semaines des
Américains ont dit voilà ils ont des
moyens de renseignements des moyens et
aussi une évidemment comme ils sont les
dans le leadership aujourd'hui des
modèles démocratie ils ont plus de
moyens pour le faire et plus de raison
de le faire parce que la Chine est un
vrai challenge ça va être défi pour le
monde démocratique donc tout ça c'est en
conduit quand même à penser qu'à défaut
de de lancer des des accusations
précises il faut quand même consommer
fit
de se poser la question mais c'est vrai
que ça ça pose la question de la limite
en fait de la protection qu'on met parce
que est-ce que c'est en effet imposé par
les États-Unis et on se pose la question
pour la Chine on pourrait se poser la
question pour alors c'est quoi c'est des
applis qui viennent de de pays qui ne
sont pas en démocratie est-ce que en
fait c'est ça c'est quel on se donne
nous indépendamment des États-Unis et
même presque de l'Europe pour pour se
protéger ou pas quand est-ce qu'on
dessine parce que la Chine oui la Chine
d'accord peut-être c'est un problème
alors pourquoi on fait du commerce avec
la Chine et on leur laisse beaucoup de
technologie beaucoup de développement
industriel on pourrait se poser la
question avant même l'appli de savoir si
on a intérêt à faire ça je comprends pas
très bien en fait on n'a pas de
stratégie en fait pour délimiter quand
on doit accepter une appli ou pas
très très clairement ils nous vendront
la corde pour les tendres est-ce que
c'est
combien de sociétés chinoises on doit
bannir de de nos échanges quoi on peut
ce qui est intéressant dans notre
stratégie à nous et l'initiative de
Claude malure elle démonte c'est que il
y a 20 ans on se posait pas la question
on était dans l'air un peu de la naïveté
on vendait des biens duo civils
militaire à la Chine sans se poser
aucune question aujourd'hui c'est un
débat côté européen côté français on
sent qu'il y a des questions et que ça
ça bouillonne là dessus je dirais qu'il
y a encore une fois l'exemple Huawei en
France a été démontré on n'était pas
dans la la remorque américaine mais on a
quand même interdit de fait même si
officiellement on dit pas qu'on interdit
Huawei mais il y a une loi qui empêche
quand même
quasiment Huawei où ZTE et d'autres
constructeurs chinois d'avoir accès à
notre marché Telecom donc
si on grossissait un peu on est on suit
les États-Unis si vous voulez quand même
qui ont les éléments là-dessus après
est-ce que la question fondamentale a
été abordé tout à l'heure toutes les
sociétés chinoises ont des cellules du
parfum 95% des boîtes chinoises ont des
cellules du Parti communiste chez elle
la loi de 2017 de renseignement elle
s'applique à tout le monde donc
sous couvert de données sensibles alors
là TikTok évidemment mais n'importe
quelle entreprise chinoise si vous
voulez au titre de l'article enfin de la
loi 2017 on pourra l'interdire en France
là il se trouve que il peut y avoir
de l'espionnage et de donner sensible
donc on y va mais la limite va être
assez tenue à démontrer en fait dans une
logique de disons politiques de
puissance que les Américains appellent
pas politique alors il y a pas la
traduction en français donc disons
politiques de puissance et non pas de
pouvoir
il y a une instrumentalisation est-ce
qu'on appelle en fait une arsenalisation
des interdépendances et en particulier
de technologie c'est à dire qu'on part
du principe par prévention que il faut
absolument empêcher la Chine pour des
raisons stratégiques d'intérêt empêcher
la Chine d'avoir accès à un maximum de
données à nos marchés et même infinie à
nos cerveaux en réalité parce que ce qui
se joue avec les capacités
algorithmiques on va peut-être parler
aussi de la puissance de l'algorithme de
TikTok par exemple c'est d'ailleurs tout
le sujet américain et d'ailleurs qui
date de Trump en réalité de 2019-2020
c'est à ce moment-là que ça a commencé
c'est une capacité de manipulation de
masse personnalisée on est capable de
nous cibler individuellement et de façon
absolument massive donc de créer de
l'ingérence deux chiffres sur le nombre
d'utilisateurs un milliard 700 millions
d'utilisateurs actifs dans le monde et
150 millions en Europe donc c'est un
succès rapide absolument donc on peut
dire au contraire l'algorithme justement
à ce moment-là
c’est grâce à cet algorithme que le
succès est là c'est ça c'est une machine
à scroller
sans fin or le cerveau a besoin de
limite donc en fait on peut passer
absolument énormément de temps sur cette
application sur des formats extrêmement
courts et pour rejoindre ce que vous
disiez très justement tout à l'heure la
question de de la puissance de
l'algorithme du Tik Tok en fait il y a
une il y a une il y a une thèse
aujourd'hui qui est très très répandue
qui commence vraiment à être très
populaire aux États-Unis reprise par un
certain tristanari ce qui une espèce de
lanceur d'alerte de Google et qui
explique en fait c'est une stratégie
chinoise en deux temps pour abêtir
finalement d'une certaine façon nos
opinions occidentales
c'est une forme ce qu'ils appellent ce
que les Américains appellent une démence
numérique de façon à ce que dans un
second temps on soit tellement affaibli
cognitivement qu'on soit complètement
pour eux on va on va terminer sur le le
les effets sur le cerveau parce que
c'est vraiment une partie passionnante
du du débat mais je vous propose vous
disiez que finalement l'appli Tik Tok
elle était déjà interdite dans certains
ministères régaliens confirmation avec
le porte-parole du gouvernement c'était
le 1er mars dernier au sortir de du
Conseil des ministres on écoute Olivier
Vérant
de la République de la première ministre
ou des membres du gouvernement nous
disposons de téléphones professionnels
qui de toute façon ne tolère pas
l'installation de quelle application de
type réseau social que ce soit donc
aucun téléphone professionnel de
ministre n'est équipé de Tik Tok ou
d'autres applications
ensuite dans le cas des ministères dit
régalien notamment la défense ou
l'intérieur mais pas que il a été déjà
assuré que sur les téléphones demandés
en tous les cas que sur les téléphones
d'usage professionnel des agents au
niveau central ils ne puissent pas être
installés d'application de réseaux
sociaux de type Tik Tok ou autre une
réflexion est en cours dans d'autres
ministères nous attendons aussi des
rapports des avis de la CNIL au niveau
français et au niveau européen pour sa
tuer de manière plus générale Claude
malurey est-ce qu'il faut aller encore
plus loin
ou ce content se dire les mystères
régaliens ça suffit est-ce qu'on
interdit à tous les fonctionnaires alors
c'est une vraie question pour moi je
veux pas vous donner la réponse
aujourd'hui parce que c'est le but de la
commission va servir à faire qu'on a
lancé donc si je pourrais si si je
présume des des conclusions c'est pas
vraiment une commission d'enquête et on
va voir à la fin néanmoins je me dis
qu'à partir à partir du moment où la
Commission européenne le Parlement
européen je parle même pas des autres
gouvernement mais la Commission
européenne le Parlement européen ils ont
quand même jeté un pavé dans la main il
y a 15 jours en plus ils ont pas dit on
va demander à nos fonctionnaires de plus
télécharger l'appli ils ont dit vous
avez 15 jours pour le faire la
Commission européenne d'habitude elle va
pas à cette vitesse là si elle va à
cette vitesse là c'est que c'est aperçu
qu'il y avait quelque chose donc en
faisant cela ils ouvrent une boîte de
Pandore
ils ne disent pas pourquoi ils disent
vaguement qu'il s'agit de transfert de
données ils veulent pas dire plus parce
qu'ils veulent pas d'incident
diplomatique probablement avec la Chine
ou avec d'autres pays mais ils disent il
y a un problème on vient de découvrir
qui a un problème majeur au point que on
interdit à nos fonctionnaires ça veut
dire et c'est bien ce que je compte leur
demander dans la commission d'enquête ça
veut dire il y a des raisons et moi je
vais demander ces raisons et s'il y a
des raisons pour la Commission
européenne ou le Parlement européen et
évidemment les mêmes raisons pour tous
les gouvernements européens et commencer
par le gouvernement français puisqu'on
est en France donc je compte bien
demander aussi au gouvernement français
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire est-ce que
vous avez je suppose que quand la
Commission européenne prend cette
décision au gouvernement français de se
dit immédiatement on va peut-être quand
même aller leur demander de quoi il
s'agit donc voilà il y a toutes ces
questions là
comme je vous dis c'est une boîte de
Pandore qu'on ouvre et il va falloir des
explications alors je voudrais grâce à
vous Emilie qu'on se pose la question de
la communication quand même des
personnalités politiques parce que Tik
Tok ça fait partie des armes de
communication
il y a notamment un ancien ministre dont
on va parler forcément si vous êtes allé
déjà sur Tik Tok vous avez pas pu louper
les vidéos de Jean-Baptiste Djebari
ex-ministre des transports ça vous fait
rire mais en effet c'était l'un des
premiers à se lancer sur la plateforme
lui il l'a fait en juin 2021 l'ancien
ministre cumule plus d'un million
d'abonnés et dans le cadre de ses
fonctions passées donc d'aix-ministre ou
actuelle et aujourd'hui président du
conseil d'administration d'opium une
société spécialisée dans les voitures à
hydrogène il use et il abuse des vidéos
on le regarde tout de suite là c'est un
extrait où il vantait les mérites de son
ministère
[Musique]
voilà donc là il voulait dire c'est très
bien d'être au ministère du travail
parce que du transport puisqu'on lui
disait que c'était pas terrible
Jean-Baptiste jbbari alors il est
surnommé le roi de Tik Tok alors c'est
bien sur pas le seul politique à cette
relancé sur cette plateforme les uns et
les autres avec plus ou moins de succès
on fait le grand saut numérique
notamment pour la présidentielle 2022
alors qui a le plus de succès au-delà de
Monsieur jeberg alors évidemment
Emmanuel Macron il bénéficie de sa Nord
et toriété de candidats 2017 puis
président puis Présidente il cumule près
de 4 millions d'abonnés dans un style
décontracté face caméra il répond le
plus souvent aux questions des tics
d'auteurs Tic-Toc histoire de
transmettre une image décalée peut-être
plus authentique plus directe et parfois
un peu plus fun on l'écoute aussi
ne pas pousser le développement de
l'utilisation de l'hydrogène vert en
France on y va on le pousse xefario on a
même été un des premiers pays à le faire
puisque la France s'est dotée en 2018
d'un plan hydrogène
voilà donc un style beaucoup plus
décontracté qui conteste beaucoup par
rapport à ses discours lyriques ça
posture à l'international beaucoup plus
formelle peut-être un moyen pour lui de
montrer toutes les facettes de son
talent un autre exemple Jean-Luc
Mélenchon très bon aussi sur ce réseau
il hésite pas à se mettre en scène avec
ce brin de second degré qu'on lui
connaît on le voit là juste avant un
débat contre Éric Zemmour c'était aussi
pendant la présidentielle la campagne de
la présidentielle 2022
[Musique]
tu préfères mon débat avec Zemmour c'est
le troisième
et oui finalement il nous fait rire
alors Marine Le Pen qui a pourtant
retravaillé son image on se souvient des
chats toute cette amélioration elle a
pas eu beaucoup de succès sur TikTok et
Éric Zemmour non plus faut dire que
l'exercice c'est pas facile outre les
codes et l'esthétique il faut publier de
nombreuses vidéos chaque semaine essayer
de publier interagir avec sa communauté
marquer les esprits sans lacer et sans
faire de faux pas alors justement des
faux pas on en termine là-dessus il y en
a quelques-uns oui alors il y a eu des
erreurs notamment le roi de TikTok
Jean-Baptiste Djebari qui a choqué sa
communauté il y a peu de temps il a
voulu se moquer de l'utilisation
gouvernementale du 49-3 il a pas trouvé
mieux que de faire référence à Dammer
qui est une série sur Netflix qui parle
d'un meurtrier
et donc il a supprimé ses vidéos donc
c'est pas toujours facile ça peut
peut-être aider à intéresser les jeunes
à la politique
finalement c'est un moyen pour les
responsable politique de s'adresser à
leur futur électeurs si on est cohérent
Claude malurey d'un côté on voit des
états l'Union européenne bon bref je
vais pas refaire la liste qui sont en
train de d'interdire Tik Tok à la il
faut y venir ma question qui à leur
fonctionnaires de l'autre on a des
hommes politiques des personnalités
politiques qui utilisent ce qui est
Macron doit continuer de communiquer sur
même si c'est un bon moyen de parler aux
jeunes
le problème c'est que tant qu'on n'aura
pas décidé
d'une interdiction plus vaste que celle
d'aujourd'hui et c'est ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure l'un et l'autre il
y a un problème on est dans une
démocratie on est dans une démographie
ou on va pas commencer à interdire des
des obligations tu as aussi en a pas de
preuve ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point c'est que
il y a une différence entre être un
émetteur et être un récepteur que
Emmanuel Macron mais je peux vous dire
que son téléphone professionnel à
l'Élysée comme celui d'olive et l'autre
ils ont pas l'application Tik Tok donc
ils sont dans leur studio il
communique
à la publicité de du site pour le moment
en France en tout cas parce que aux
États-Unis ça avait déjà commencé mais
en France en tout cas pour le moment
l'affaire TikTok si je peux dire
l'affaire de la Commission européenne
elle a commencé il y a 15 jours donc
jusqu'à présent alors on n'a pas de
raison de ne pas communiquer sur après
tout TikTok pose des problèmes
spécifiques comme je le disais tout à
l'heure mais si on commence à aller dans
ce sens-là toutes les toutes les
plateformes posent des problèmes
différents mais pose aussi des problèmes
massifs alors vous avez évoqué la
question de l'interdiction tiens je vous
propose une citation du patron de la
commission fédérale américaine des
communications il s'appelle Brendan car
il dit Tic-Toc c'est un loup déguisé en
agneau Antoine ils embar est-ce que ça
veut dire que l'État américain peut
aller plus loin peut aller jusqu'à une
interdiction de Tik Tok assez c'est je
vois que c'est le Sénat américain qui
justement va étudier la question donc
mais juste un mot sur les interdictions
de Tik Tok pour les fonctionnaires
américains européens ou français bon
Véran a montré que on peut pas dans les
téléphones professionnels français
installés d'applications aux États-Unis
dans les ministères régaliens notamment
au Pentagone on ne peut pas non plus
donc c'est un peu de la fonctionnaires
européens certes mais je rappelle que
l'usage de Tik Tok c'est 15/24 ans dans
les ministères
beaucoup de gens qui voilà donc là on
est encore dans les effets d'annonces
qui sont pas très contraignants qui sont
un peu le début tout ça après est-ce que
les États-Unis peuvent aller plus loin
bien sûr Donald Trump voulait entre
guillemets americaniser Tik Tok en
faisant racheter finalement la filiale
aux États-Unis oui il avait rencontré le
patron de Microsoft je me souviens bien
mais je crois savoir l'administration
Biden et pas non plus opposée à ça et on
pourrait évidemment mais là faudrait
dans ces cas-là que la NSA donc le
renseignement électronique américain ou
l'armée américaine arrive à quand même à
montrer à démontrer que véritablement il
y a des bacs d'or il y a des choses qui
sont problématiques sur l'interdiction
est-ce d'ailleurs est-ce que c'est
possible parce que il y aura des moyens
il y a un texte il y a un projet de loi
qui vient de sortir au Sénat américain
l'un qui passe en étude pour
l'interdiction totale de Tik Tok partout
pour tout le monde sur tous les vivaces
juste un ban définitif donc espacement
partiel sur les device il est en études
et surtout il est intervenu tout début
mars et les sorties et surtout il
intervient il a été publié enfin sorti
annoncé communiquer trois jours après le
projet de loi donc là il est très
intéressant ce projet de Lola parce que
pour le coup c'est pour le coup de la
censure pure il n'y a pas que la Chine
ils ont évacué la question Tik Tok
chinoise en mettant toutes les
plateformes potentiellement posant des
risques systémiques en termes de cyber
cyber menace cyberespionnage influence
guerre informationnel etc pour tout un
tas de pays l'Iran la Chine et tout un
tas d'autres donc ils ont fait une
espèce de
l'intitulé liste américaine classique
donc là c'est ce projet de loi là et et
puis il y en a un autre qui était
intervenu trois jours avant qui était
spécifiquement donnant les pouvoirs
spécifiques à Biden lui-même pour
interdire TikTok pour des questions
évidemment aux États-Unis sacrées de
sécurité nationale et simplement et donc
là et ce qui est très intéressant si on
suit le mouvement on va on y va on y va
parce qu'il y a cette coalition bip
partisane mais ce qui est très
intéressant aussi c'est que vous avez
tous les activistes les ONG type SCI
elle lui et cetera qui sont en train de
dire mais en fait aux États-Unis on a un
truc qui s'appelle le premier amendement
de la Constitution américaine qui en
fait sacralise le fruit de mauve speech
c'est-à-dire la liberté d'expression
mais pas l'américaine version
maximaliste et de ce point de vue là on
a un sujet de droit énorme mais c'est
intéressant que ça pose une question
beaucoup plus générale de de la capacité
des démocraties à se défendre face à des
régimes autoritaires finalement il y a
ça derrière et quand on parle de liberté
d'expression c'est c'est une de nos
valeurs les plus importantes donc voilà
c'est cet équilibre qui est qui est
compliqué et c'est ce que vous disiez
pour ça il faut la preuve quoi avant d'y
aller je pense qu'on est en train
d'avoir des vous avez tout à fait raison
et moi je plaide depuis longtemps pour
des réactions beaucoup plus fortes des
démocraties vis-à-vis des régimes
autoritaires qui
de prendre de l'importance depuis
notamment le début des années 2000 mais
on est en train actuellement peut-être
de se déniyser un peu l'Ukraine a déniés
l'Europe de la même façon des
applications comme Tik Tok ou grinder ou
pas avoir une forme on pourrait parler
de grinder qui est un sujet intéressant
sont en train de montrer comme
d'habitude dans la lutte contre les
régimes autoritaires les États-Unis sont
en pointes et je veux pouvoir le
reprocher bien entendu mais je pense
qu'on est en train petit à petit
de se dire qu'il faut renverser le
courant alors je suis très heureux
d'ailleurs que le courant soit renversé
de lui-même après l'énorme erreur
stratégique de Poutine d'avoir envahi
l'Ukraine et que tout le monde se rende
compte aujourd'hui qu'il y a une
alliance des dictateurs qui est en train
de revenir après quand on avait cru qu'à
la fin du 20e siècle on avait gagné les
démocraties avaient gagné aujourd'hui le
boucher de Moscou le génocidaire des
Ouigours en Chine Docteur Folamour de
Corée du Nord le massacreur de femmes
d'Iran sont en train de
de se regrouper mais il se regroupe dans
une situation beaucoup moins facile que
je que c'était au cours des 20 dernières
années néanmoins
je pense que vous vous répondre à votre
question est-ce qu'on peut dans des
démocraties
c'est bien c'est bien comme ça c'est
l'exemple de Tik Tok et très explicite
de ce point de vue là en Chine Tik Tok
et modéré de façon complètement
différente alors du complètement
différent et profite de des failles de
la de nos démocratie pour mettre un
contenu de crétinisation si vous voulez
la transition pour le dernier chapitre
du débats qui utilisent ce mot tout en
protégeant ses enfants avec pas plus de
40 minutes par jour et du conduit
beaucoup plus Périgueux alors il y a des
vidéos
je vous interrompre parce que c'est un
peu le thème de la chronique de Quentin
Calmette et juste là et qui va pouvoir
nous rejoindre bonsoir Quentin
effectivement ça fait quoi 18 mois à peu
près que la Chine a décidé de d'agir
face au risque d'addiction des jeunes
alors pas seulement à Tik Tok au jeu
vidéo c'est ça déjà fait ça c'est une
mesure de santé publique selon les
autorités chinoises pour lutter contre
les addictions mais aussi contre le
surpoids et la myopie qui sont d'autres
conséquences liées à l'excès de temps
passé devant les jeux vidéo
effectivement donc en Chine en septembre
2021 les autorités ont donc mis en place
un dispositif une réglementation un
jeune chinois de moins de 18 ans ne
pourra pas jouer plus de trois heures
par semaine au jeu vidéo en ligne soit
une heure par jour les vendredis samedi
et dimanche de plus les mineurs non
l'autorisation de jouer contre 20h et
21h ça d'ailleurs fait que certains
serveurs de jeux en ligne ont eu
quelques difficultés à absorber tout ce
monde au même moment le soir et lors des
vacances scolaires enfin une heure par
jour leur est accordée concrètement les
joueurs doivent indiquer leur numéro de
carte d'identité pour s'identifier sur
les plateformes en ligne si bien qu'en
novembre 2022 et bien un an plus tard un
rapport au gouvernemental chinois
indiqué que le pays avait résolu je cite
le problème d'addiction des jeunes grâce
à ces mesures très contraignantes 75%
des mineurs jouent au moins de 3 heures
par semaine selon ce rapport au
gouvernemental dernière indicateur qui
lui pour le coup ne trompe pas les
ventes en Chine de jeux vidéo ont connu
l'an dernier leur premier repli depuis
10 ans écrivait la tribune dans cet
article 101 mois ces ventes ont baissé
de 10,3% atteignant néanmoins la somme
colossale de
265,9 milliards de yon soit 36,3
milliards d'euros donc la Chine entend
protégée ces jeunes ce qu'il lance une
autre question est-ce qu'on va vers une
guerre des cerveaux oui c'est ça le
débat qui se pose maintenant faut-il
limiter le temps d'exposition aux écrans
y compris en France puisque la Chine le
fait c'est l'une des questions que se
pose Olivier babot depuis la publication
de son ouvrage la tyrannie du
divertissement merci Quentin vous
m'offrez la transition pour aller
justement accueillir Olivier babot dans
notre débat bonsoir vous êtes professeur
à l'Université de de Bordeaux et votre
livre est publié aux éditions Buchet
Chastel vous parlez de guerre des
cerveaux vous aussi pourquoi peut-on
utiliser cette cette terminologie
la terminologie est utilisée par la
Chine est aussi très forte il parle
d'opium mental alors souvenez-vous chez
Marx c'est la religion qui est l'opium
du peuple aujourd'hui c'est le jeu vidéo
qui est une forme d'opium mental le la
rhétorique est très simple et très
explicite pour pour la Chine ce qui fait
la puissance d'une nation économique et
militaire ce sont les innovations ce
sont les technologies et qu'est-ce qui
fait les innovations c'est les cerveaux
donc les cerveaux c'est ce qui est le
plus important au 21e siècle dans un
siècle hyper technologique il nous faut
de plus en plus de cerveaux et des
cerveaux hyper formés or on sait que les
écrans ont des effets sur le
fonctionnement des cerveaux des enfants
et à plus long terme de l'adulte et donc
il faut agir et donc et donc ça je
reprends ce que vient de nous détailler
Quentin calmé ça explique la décision de
l'État chinois de limiter le temps passé
on va dire en simplifiant face aux
écrans aux jeux vidéos
c'est la seule raison c'est une crainte
sur ce sujet là il y a plein d'études il
y a un livre très bon de Nicolas qui
s'appelle The shallows what the internat
is doing to mind qu'est-ce que internet
est en train de faire un autre esprit
ils font ils montrent que que internet
c'est pas seulement les réseaux sociaux
il y a d'autres problèmes liés à la
lecture en ligne par exemple mais est en
train de changer le fonctionnement de
votre cerveau provoque des formes
d'embouteillage cognitives qui limitent
par exemple la capacité à nourrir notre
mémoire à long terme tous ces effets là
on est en train de les découvrir on les
découvre aussi sur le développement de
l'enfant c'est très bien que maintenant
que l'écran pour les enfants de moins de
4 ans a des effets extrêmement
extrêmement nocifs ça a les effets tout
au long de la vie sur notre capacité à
nous concentrer et notre capacité
mynésique notre capacité à nous souvenir
on sait que plus on utilise son cerveau
chez les jeunes pardon son téléphone
portable moins par exemple on a de
mémoire l'enjeu c'est que dans une
civilisation vous n'êtes jamais laissé
pour dire en silence ou dans la capacité
peut-être à vous ennuyer ou à réfléchir
bien vous avez moins de capacités à être
créatif à développer avoir des
initiatives donc vous êtes en train de
nous dire bon on parle souvent de la
placidité du cerveau mais que c'est un
nouveau cerveau qui est en train de
naître c'est ça j'essaye de bien
comprendre ce que vous expliquer en tout
cas ce sont des organisations
différentes et des fonctionnements
différents qui vont d'ailleurs beaucoup
fonctionner sur le mécanisme de la
récompense immédiate donnée par le shoot
de dopamine que vous procure par exemple
un live sur les réseaux sociaux et qui
va créer ces phénomènes de de
d'addiction aux écrans il faut jamais
oublier que le modèle économique de
beaucoup de plateformes c'est la
maximisation du temps passé dessus cette
maximisation fait de vous non pas le
client mais la matière première en
quelque sorte de ces plateformes tout
simplement alors restez avec nous
évidemment Olivier Babeau j'aimerais
vous entendre les uns les autres sur
cette question là je commence peut-être
avec vous Antoine zambard si je si je
caricature volontairement Tik Tok
machine à des cérébrer les les enfants
occidentaux
là c'est plutôt un débat qu'il faudrait
avoir je pense avec un psychologue ou un
chronobiologiste ou quelqu'un qui suit
le rythme de l'enfant oui mais en termes
alors à ce moment là je reviens vers
votre expertise sur le l'espionnage ou
le ou la guerre entre entre nos
démocraties et les régimes autoritaires
est-ce que finalement
un réseau social peut être un outil dans
cette dans cette guerre bien sûr enfin
on a vu que ça pouvait à la fois en
termes d'influence et aujourd'hui on
voit de plus en plus et d'ailleurs la
France structure pour lutter de plus en
plus contre les fake news alors
aujourd'hui on est plus sur le côté ruse
Wagner mais le je pense c'est important
aujourd'hui que via TiK ToK on comprenne
aussi que la Chine et une puissance qui
fait de la désinformation qui est
extrêmement puissante là-dessus il y a
eu un rapport de l'IRSEM l'an dernier
qu'il avait très bien démontré donc
aujourd'hui je dirais que c'est ça après
sur le le côté dessert des Cérébra si
pardon et sur le temps 1h30 chaque jour
contre je crois deux fois moins sur sur
Twitter ou Instagram évidemment que ça
pose ça pose des problèmes et qui va
falloir contrôler ça et midi vous dire
réagir en écoutant
je pense à la télévision et à la
publicité on disait ça moi dans mon
enfance on disait on va s'abrutir parce
que vous prenez vous vous regardez
[Musique]
regarde très très peu en tout cas
beaucoup moins la télévision plus vous
êtes élevé dans les chaises sociales
mais vous regardez les écrans en fait et
en particulier la télévision qui a quand
même des effets de passivité mais ce qui
est vrai c'est que le problème c'est
qu'on peut pas condamner les écrans en
bloc parce qu'en effet il permettent il
donne accès aussi à plein de capacités
ils peuvent être utilisés de façon
extrêmement puissante et on peut pas
élever les enfants loin des capacités
numériques aujourd'hui c'est important
qui qui s'initie le problème est
probablement un problème de d'équilibre
dans l'usage avec un usage qui parfois
malheureusement est plutôt celui de la
passivité plutôt que celui de la
création à la limite quitte à aller sur
Tik Tok autant être celui qui danse et
celui qui travaille sa chorégraphie
plutôt que celui qui va scroller pendant
des heures le problème c'est que les
gens qui se scrollent sont une très
grande majorité sur les réseaux sociaux
en fait vous avez plus 80% des gens qui
qui en fait sont des observateurs
passifs à ce moment-là vous parliez de
de démence numérique c'était à moi en
préparant l'émission c'est la première
fois que j'ai j'ai lu ça vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure mais c'est quoi
c'est une c'est une thèse qui vient des
États-Unis là aussi là aussi
une question qu'on a déjà évoqué
longuement sur l'opium sur
la bêtisement la critinisation des
esprits occidentaux pour mieux les
manipuler mais en fait on est en train
de passer à côté de quelque chose par
exemple enfin on tourne autour mais on
n'est pas en train de
vous donner des choses donc je vais
nommer ce dont on est en train de parler
si on replace les choses dans un
contexte que j'ai au politique qui
aujourd'hui extrêmement disons aigu
c'est en fait ce que notre propre séma a
dit déclaré et martelé c'est la guerre
gris chef d'état-major pardon merci
excusez-moi
je croyais mise en masse c'est en fait
on est en train d'entrer dans une heure
qui s'appelle la guerre hybride où on va
être dans une zone grise permanente je
dis bien permanente tout le temps ça va
être la nouvelle aire entre guerre et
paix mais sous le seuil et dans ce champ
là énorme de de la militarisation du
monde il va y avoir une question qui est
celle des guerres informationnels et de
leur qui qui n'a rien de nouveau sous le
soleil et vous avez raison de le dire
les médias de masse autrefois la
propagande en fait est pratiquement le
corollaire même d'une démocratie mais je
reviens à notre débat est-ce que Tik Tok
est un outil dans cette nouvelle guerre
là on est en train d'entrer dans une
heure des luttes informationnelles et en
amont les guerres cognitives donc on va
taper nos systèmes cognitifs pour en
fait leur faire absorber ce que des pays
étrangers sous forme d'ingérence on vit
on t'envie que l'on croit et en général
les guerres informationnelles et
cognitives ce n'est pas de vendre leur
modèle idéologique pas du tout c'est de
nous perturber dans le nôtre c'est de la
confusion c'est le doute c'est la
polarisation c'est la brutalisation et
parlons on parle beaucoup des enfants
mais les complotistes les
conspirationnistes sont des adultes
aujourd'hui et les mouvements
séparationnels sont des adultes
aujourd'hui et questionneur risque de
quoi de ces narratifs en fait et qui
deviennent organiques chez nous donc on
a un énorme sujet j'apporte de l'eau à
votre moulin avec cette enquête sur la
més information justement alors là on
revient aux jeunes mes informations des
jeunes rapport à la science et aux
paranormal c'est une étude qui avait
menée l'Ifop pour la Fondation reboot et
pour la Fondation Jean Jaurès regardez
ces chiffres selon ce sondage 33% des
jeunes estiment aujourd'hui que la
science apporte à l'homme plus de bien
que de mal c'est beaucoup moins vous le
voyez en dessous que il y a 50 ans ils
étaient 55% en 1972 et ces jeunes ils
sont de plus en plus perméables hôtesses
complotisme vous évoquez à ce moment-là
à l'instant alors je vais pas toutes les
citer mais la terre est plate les
Américains sont pas allés sur la lune
plus grave si on parle de santé on peut
avorter sans risque avec des produits à
base de de plantes et alors quand on
regarde on a voilà ils ont ils ont
proposé une liste de de tests
complotistes aux jeunes qu'ils ont
sondés il y a 79% des utilisateurs
quotidiens de Tik Tok qui adhèrent à au
moins une fake news et 64% des
utilisateurs en général qui adhèrent à
une fake news est-ce que pour autant
Olivier Babou je reviens vers vous on
est-ce que on peut dire que Tik Tok a
une idéologie complotiste ou alors
est-ce que ça a pas de sens ou est-ce
que c'est plutôt du business tout
simplement
oui parmi les statistiques il y avait
notamment un jeune sursis qui pensait
que la terre était plate alors qu'un
autre sondage avait montré que c'était
seulement neuf Français sur 10 pardon
sur 100 pardon donc c'était plutôt pire
chez les jeunes sur 100 on n'est pas ce
point-là c'est pire chez les jeunes que
chez que chez les adultes en fait il y a
même pas besoin de supposer qu'il y ait
une volonté de nuit ou une organisation
peut-être qu'il y en a une j'en sais
rien peut-être qu'il y a une
organisation de la désinformation mais
il y a même pas besoin de supposer qu'il
y en ait il suffit en fait qu'on donne
aux gens ce qu'il leur plaît ou ce
qu'ils veulent de la façon la moins
limitée possible et dans ce contexte
vous avez évidemment Tik Tok mais pas
seulement je pense qu'il faut pas d'être
diabolisé Tik Tok c'est celui qui a le
plus de croissance aujourd'hui qui est
le plus efficace qui met qui porte le
modèle à son paroxysme mais c'est pas le
seul ce modèle de la facilité c'est
aussi le modèle du plaisir immédiat qui
empêche la mise à distance la distance
c'est celle aussi qui permet le recul
réflexif et qui font et qui sur la
culture générale qui permet de prendre
de la distance aussi face à tous les
sophistes à tous les mécanismes qui
peuvent vous entraîner dans des dans des
croyances délirantes allez à vous le mot
de la conclusion Claude malurey
malheureusement ce débat il est passé à
toute vitesse c'est plutôt bon signe et
est-ce qu'on peut est-ce qu'on peut
faire marche arrière quoi c'est à dire
que cette génération je simplifie
génération TikTok est-ce qu'elle peut
s'instruire
s'informer correctement je pense deux
choses la première c'est Obama résume
très bien les choses dans un interview
qu'il a donné à the Atlantic il y a
quelques temps en disant les réseaux
sociaux sont devenus l'une des
principales menaces pour nos démocraties
et Dieu sait Obama il est bien placé
pour savoir quel est la puissance des
réseaux sociaux c'est pas seulement du
problème du temps de cerveau c'est le
problème de la polarisation dont vous
parliez c'est le problème de
l'affrontement permanent c'est le
problème des élections truquées etc etc
donc de ce point de vue là vous avez
tout à fait raison
c'est un vrai un véritable danger pour
le cerveau des enfants et pour nos
démocraties dernier côté et c'est la
deuxième partie de la question que vous
posiez on a toujours
dans les nouvelles technologies il y a
toujours eu des nouvelles technologies
et ça s'accélère bien entendu il y a
toujours un temps de retard et c'est là
la force des démocratie il y a un temps
de sidération un temps où elle le
comprennent pas un temps elle se
chamaille pour savoir comment on va
répondre et puis petit à petit et
finissent dans le temps de l'action je
dois vous donner des outils j'espère que
c'est ça le notre avenir et on suivra
votre commission d'enquête évidemment de
près merci beaucoup merci à tous Anthony
dommage j'appelle vos livres trahison à
la DGSE ça c'est le tout dernier paru et
puis juste avant un peu plus alors on le
voit maintenant Francine et les gens
dangereux celui qui est un peu plus dans
dans le thème de notre de notre débat je
vous dis à demain et notez votre
prochain rendez-vous politique c'est
dans la matinale et c'est Olivier du
stop ministre du Travail qui sera
l'invité Dorian Mancini à demain
[Musique]